[Music]
thank you
[Music]
and in weird things in space news
starting your episode off with blatant
self-referential news positional
re-piping bold move Rick and Morty a
bold move indeed oh what's it now I mean
if you're forcing me to send something
in this thing that flag's annoying me
because there's no way there's room for
the star section in that little part
that's off the screen this is just red
and white stripes all the way to the
pole and you know it what did you do you
turning monster Morty didn't do anything
but I'm still gonna issue a sin for the
convenient timing of the dinosaur aliens
showing up right as the teacher was
accusing Morty of always bringing
terrible like this down on the school
you know how we feel about that in these
quarters starting your episode off with
blatant self-referential news positional
re-piping twice in the first two minutes
bold move Rick and Morty a bold move
indeed if these aliens want Earth
they'll have to go through Egypt and
they can ask mummies how that goes man
are we talking about the Boris Karloff
mummy the Brendan Fraser mummy or the
Tom Cruise mummy I mean we could also be
talking about the Cushing Lee mummy or
the Jason Scott Lee mummy or even they
have it in Costello mummy which is also
basically the Boris Carl off mummy but
more of a funny mummy and then there's
the wax work Mommy not to mention the
Charlton Heston mummy which if it wasn't
for scream Factor we'd all forgotten
about him and better for it in the end
there are just too many [ __ ] mummies
to wrap my head around this statement
and I think I might cry I want my mommy
monkeys went bald hilarious but in what
world do you know enough to No Monkeys
existed but not enough to know about the
development of homo sapiens how did
these dinosaurs even get in the U.N
building did they install a dino door
pretty considerate of this long neck to
hold their head like this when the
imaginary camera's on a close-up and
then extend their neck completely for
the wide shots the imaginary
cinematographer thanks you but surely
there was some point between gunpowder
and something called Amazon Prime we
don't know what Amazon Prime really is
either we just know that 130 or so
disappears from our checking account
every year and that allows us to then
send more money to an invisible entity
that often sends something in return
that we didn't even ask for
every fridge full but why in a post-care
city Society Like This Not only would
you never have to stock up on stuff you
never have to cook at home either I mean
you could if that's your thing but I'm
guessing most fridges would just sit
mostly unused while everyone picked up
free Five Guys I can see the headline is
unemployment at 100 but someone had to
write this article someone had to print
it and someone had to distribute it so
how exactly is no one working currently
somehow pre-filling in only the M's on
several lines of your crossword puzzle I
do think it's kind of funny that you're
all basically Jerry now Rick per usual
would be the richest TV sins show teases
us with pandas falling in a snake
wearing mini skirt and doesn't follow
through on either forcing us to come
through in the clutch
you're welcome does anyone know how to
mail things to Publishers not keep
making this my hill to die on but even
if they did who would be able to publish
the book who would even pick up the mail
sure maybe it's technology of some sort
but I don't see any cool robot Butler so
I'm calling shenanigans the only thing
that can make the name of this
restaurant more wonderful is if Beau
Bridges was the one inside cooking the
food and since that's not not the case
here's the sin at first it was fun
spending all day watching whatever
YouTube Auto plays after the last one
Auto played insinuating it ever gets
tiring letting YouTube videos autoplay
give in to the algorithm the algorithm
loves you the algorithm is your friend
how often are you westworlding me
calling it westworlding instead of Dr
goldfoot in the Bikini Machining there's
an order to these things if you get rid
of the dinosaurs you can host the Oscars
in a situation where one has all the
leverage and said person chooses their
reward to be the most thankless job on
the entire planet over candling around
flammable Flora the gateways are
see-through found a green swirl so now
you can see where you're going I like
these Dino Lords can they also help me
understand how the portal automatically
knows where you want to go I mean if
you're fixing our portal sins we might
as well go ahead and fix them all
they're gonna call us Laura Dern because
we're about to get elbow deep in Dino
doodoo yeah let's not reference the
parts where Laura Dern Wards off a T-Rex
and velociraptors to save kids let's
just talk about it reaching into some
which for the wreck record she's doing
in an attempt to save a dinosaur's life
you put some respect on Laura Dern's
name Rick I said clever girl earlier you
didn't even react complaining that a
reference you are also explaining wasn't
given its due in the past when are you a
Cylon or something yeah we figured they
used to hold huge outdoor concerts in
their land Amphitheater maybe this is a
silly Theory but the singing skull feed
is way more interesting than our boring
old dinosaur stories also just making
sure everyone caught that Cylon
reference a few seconds ago that's from
Battlestar Galactica and while I can't
watch you watch this video I could feel
there was very little laughter so I'm
just bringing it up here again for no
reason at all the Majestic baskets are
aren't they incredible we're even making
a series of increasingly terrible movies
about cloning them in a theme park can't
be worse than Jurassic world Dominion so
please feel free to bring the basket
Store franchise to Earth also
increasingly terrible show wants us to
laugh but honestly Jurassic world was
better than both two and three and to
pretend otherwise on any Planet strains
credulity police what fossils were wheel
shaped what fossils I say it appears
that the Rick and Morty animators are
using the repeating faceless crowd
models again which fine do what you
gotta do but this guy bugs me why is his
head so big why is it all skin tone when
others have distinct hair colors why is
he looking up to the sky as if ready to
ascend to the Rapture this one
is headed directly towards us and all of
our work it was four how are these Ultra
evolved creatures with their god-like
knowledge and wisdom unaware that they
have an arch nemesis you know everything
there is to know in the universe except
that you're being hunted by evil
sentient space rocks using a perfectly
beautiful slice of pepperoni pizza is a
hate projectile it's pizza and it's
delicious and it contains every single
food group you yum chucking waste
monsters and you had no idea about the
disastrous meteors that followed in your
wake deciding to let Anderson Cooper
interview you to tell your side of the
story also did the dinosaurs not watch
movies because if they watched
Armageddon they'd save some time there's
a formula to it a very simple formula I
mean no one knows if the meteor species
is even real deciding to let Joe Rogan
interview you to tell your side of the
story this guy created a dinosaur Avenue
sign and is replacing a current street
sign just so he can graffiti the word
sucks onto it came recognized game well
why does Tom Hanks yelling Wilson all of
a sudden sound like Dave Seville yelling
at Alvin what even is this nonsense Rick
has a gizmo that lets him see whatever
he needs to see even though he clearly
didn't type in any commands or
coordinates cliche Oscars are over
something every single person except the
academy is known for about 10 years now
somehow makes it into the episode Elon
Musk be damned we're blowing up Mars
thinking you need a reason to damn Elon
Musk we're doing something selfless
where are you though there's no way
calculations could have been done to
guarantee the safety of earth when Mars
blows up into thousands if not millions
of pieces there is so much that could go
wrong here
somewhere in Tasmania devil silently
weeps at the cruel theft of his native
tongue you may turn on the AC it's like
a thousand degrees outside
it is not orchids take your pick
check it out Rick and Morty Riders last
a full five episodes without their
portal gun crutch before giving up a
dimension where hats wear people fun but
why do the hats also have the same body
construction as people those aren't
really hats then are they they're hat
people so technically it's a dimension
where half people wear people is people
hats huh that felt good I missed you
portal gun I've missed you so much here
we go Rick and Morty time he says
directly before announcing the final
four episodes of the season are on
surprise hiatus
thank you
yeah I don't want to go to work Mr
Spicoli you're on Dangerous Ground here
you're causing a major disturbance on my
time
dinosaurs are back too
hello I'm Dr Sheldon Cooper Welcome to
Sheldon Cooper presents Fun With Flags
you're dinosaurs thought you were dead
no you pay attention to Old Rooter the
great circle of life has begun but you
see not all of us arrive together I do
think it's kind of funny that you're all
basically Jerry now
you think I'm gonna side with you over
hyper-intelligent creatures operating
Way Beyond your comprehension I have
more in common with them than you we
don't need so-called superheroes what
are the Hooters it's ought to be
here
but it isn't
gravity is pulling all the stars in the
area towards this spot now please
welcome your host an old science guy who
got rid of the dinosaurs Rick Sanchez
you'll be pleased to know this is the
last time I'm hosting these Awards